[Music]
[Music]
raise the ladder take my handling
[Music]
[Music]
in 500 years no one has ever escaped go
back to yourselves you want to talk come
on come back to yourselves you think I'm
joking
[Music]
soon we think it's fine calm down I said
calm down children I'll deal with them
[Music]
you're pretty my friends
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
little snake
you need to
[Music]
are you doing I'm gonna buy something
in five hundred years no one has ever
escaped in the towing anywhere
it's the tower so stupid
what's your name trendline I owe you my
life I'm going east my way is filled
with dangers come with me
[Music]
my journey follows the Silk Road
the Great Wall of China something is
very wrong
[Music]
gather the people immediately make
everyone see that I must help save
I've been waiting for this for a long
time
no don't touch this this is the helmet
of Genghis Khan helmet this is the
instant spark
when I have the seal of the Dragon I
will rule the world
[Music]
you know better this way
[Music]